hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster
now there are certain points in history
when economic events change the shape of
politics I think black Wednesday in 1992
that shredded the conservatives economic
reputation or the financial crash of
2008 that would finish off Labor's long
run in government well tonight some
conservatives might be worrying that
we're getting close to that territory
again today the bank of England had to
step in and buy government debt to
protect the stability of our economy
just five days after that bombshell
budget so what does the Prime Minister
and the chancellor do next change course
or continue to go for growth whatever
happens or bring you takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
what we're focused on as a government is
making sure the economy grows making
sure that businesses do well making sure
people can get into better paid jobs
that was the point of our growth plan
last week and that's what we're focused
on delivering are you going to change
course well no we're not
well the government says it will hold
its nerve and the chancellor won't quit
but the opposition says that mini budget
must be scrapped
and she needs to come to Parliament
straight away and reverse that budget
well he's just finished his conference
on a high while the conservatives are
just a few days away from their own and
it could already be make or break for
the new prime minister
we'll find out what our viewers panel
makes of the growing economic events
there they all are I noticed that one I
just quickly sliding into slot very nice
I bet you're all here now good news
we'll also have some top guests for you
including the chief secretary to the
treasury Chris philp Labor's Shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury plus
we'll speak to the man that some have
called Liz truss's favorite Economist
Gerald Lyons and much more besides on
the take
[Music]
hello good evening well just last Friday
the chancellor stood up to deliver what
was described as a mini budget and we
now know the new government wanted it to
have impact shock on all was the phrase
used by some and there was real shock
today an extraordinary intervention by
the bank of England due to fear of a
mass default of Pension funds meanwhile
in Liverpool labor wrapped up its
conference and called for the immediate
recall of parliament well a little
earlier I spoke to the chief secretary
secretary to the treasury the number two
effectively in the treasury Chris philp
so today the British economy was hours
away from what could have been one of
the most serious Financial crises in
decades a run on Pension funds and if
the bank of England hadn't intervened by
buying up government bonds there could
have been mass insolvencies by this
afternoon do you take responsibility no
the bank of England did its job the bank
of England intervened in the market to
ensure Financial stability that is
exactly what the Independent Bank of
England is there to do and I think the
market has responded positively uh to
that so I think we should all be very
pleased the bank of England has done
that what we're focused on as a
government is making sure the economy
grows making sure that businesses do
well making sure people can get into
better paid jobs that was the point of
our growth plan last week and that's
what we're focused on delivering I think
everyone can agree that it is good news
that there was an intervention but I
guess the thing is why they felt the
needs to intervene in the first place
and in the five days since the budget a
third of Residential Mortgages have been
pulled from the market interest rates
are now predicted to double next year I
mean that could mean people losing their
homes and it's self-inflicted it's a
budget that decided to prioritize
helping the one people who the one group
of people who don't need help those on
over 150 000 pounds a year are you going
to change course well no we're not let
me just first of all take the point
about what the uh event on Friday the
chancellor statement was designed to do
so to be clear the abolition of the
additional rate the 45p tax Band uh
constituted less than one twentieth less
than five percent of the fiscal
Firepower that was deployed things like
the national insurance tax cut
bringing forward the cut to the basic
rate of income tax and holding down
corporation tax for businesses big and
small alike benefit everybody and there
are 30 million workers who benefit from
those National Insurance and income tax
decreases it were was a an event a
statement designed to help everybody in
the country directly and by getting the
economy to grow it will help everybody
as well now you made a point before that
about you know has this caused the
volatility in the market and I think if
you just take a step back and look at
the markets whether it's currency
markets or Bond markets interest rates
over the last year or so and the last
nine months in particular globally we've
seen quite a lot of I'm gonna have to
I'm going to have to come at you there
because you know you're talking about
global forces but it is clear that the
UK is an outlier here let's just look at
the yield now 30 years just let me
finish look at the yield on 30-year
government bonds this is the cost of UK
borrowing effectively the Bedrock of
these Pension funds that the bank of
England had to intervene to try and
support well I'm not sure this is the UK
is clear outlier so I'm not sure this
chart can be up today I checked looked
at Bond deals before coming in and the
U.S Bond rates and UK Bond rates are
pretty are pretty I don't know where
they got pretty close together right
that is up to date you can see it
dropping a little bit but you can see
the huge increase the red line is
shooting ahead of the others and you're
talking about global forces well you
also talked about interest rates right I
mean if you look at the interest rate
cycle across the globe interest rates
are increasing they're actually higher
in the United States than they are in
the United Kingdom so I think we are
looking
Global changes Global volatility it's
been happening not just in the last few
days it's been happening in the last few
months I mean the bank of Japan made an
intervention in their currency Market
just a few days ago and we're responding
to these same Global forces but the
government what the government is
focusing on because obviously the
monetary policy is the Independent Bank
of England's preserve but we're focusing
on as a government is growth is making
sure our economy is freed up to create
the jobs of the future to create better
paid jobs as well and that's what the
growth plan is designed to do we've also
so you mentioned inflation interest
rates we've also intervened decisively
in the energy markets to make sure that
households don't face bills of three
four five thousand pounds this winter
which was forecast just a few weeks ago
we're making sure the average household
doesn't pay more than two and a half
thousand pounds that is a huge
intervention that will help every single
household in this country and every
business as well it's a huge
intervention but this is partly why and
those markets are concerned as well
because look you've got this huge
intervention on the one hand you've got
tax cuts on the other and you haven't
told them how are you going to pay for
it why did you not publish the OVR why
didn't you even bother to get your sons
done that's why the chancellor of the
exchequer has said very clearly you said
it on Friday and he said it again on
Monday just in case anyone missed it
that there will be a full uh medium-term
financial plan medium term fiscal plan
set out on the 23rd of November that
will explain what his plans are but it
will include getting debt over GDP down
over the medium term it'll be fully
scored by the obr and we should also
just keep in mind that we start today
with the second lowest debt to GDP ratio
of any G7 country and billing the
question you just asked will get very
clearly and comprehensively answered
including an independent obr score on
November the 23rd okay I I will I want
to ask you a bit more about that in a
minute but just before we do because
it's really interesting talking to you
it's pretty clear that you are not
changing course you're effectively
pushing on there's going to be no
reversal of what the plan of the
government not at all because getting
because getting balances because getting
Britain's economy growing so important
important to raise wages
my point is why do you think you are
wrong and so many other people are you
were right sorry yeah there we go why do
you think you were right and so many
people are wrong I just want to look
because here's the international
monetary fund they've said given the
elevated inflation pressures in many
countries including the UK your point we
do not recommend large and untargeted
fiscal packages at this juncture as it's
important that fiscal policy does not
work at Cross purposes to monetary
policy and they go on to say the nature
of the UK measures will likely increase
inequality a really a clear message
there from the IMF against your plans
and it's not just them the former bank
of England Deputy Governor Charlie Bean
so the budget went catastrophically
wrong the chief Economist at Capital
economics the idea is going to spare on
economic growth I find difficult to
believe even Julie and Jessica the iea
usually someone who's quite Pro Liz
truss even I can't put a positive spin
on this why is the government so
confident that you're right and everyone
else is wrong what do you know that we
don't well first of all getting growth
going is is critically important to our
countries let me just answer the
question look if you look at our growth
um in recent years it needs to be higher
higher growth leads to more jobs better
pay and it makes us more able to pay the
tax bills of the future to fund the NHS
Health police and so on and that's why
the growth plan is so important it is of
course also important to be fiscally
responsible which is why the medium-term
fiscal plan and the accompanying obr
scoring is going to be set out in full
on the 23rd you know if you look at the
reaction to the statement the chancellor
statement uh quasi-parten's statement on
Friday and look at the response of
people like the CBI the confederation of
British industry look at the response of
people like the Federation of small
businesses or the British Chambers of
Commerce they all really strongly
welcome these packages and these
measures because they understand it will
help their members the businesses who
create jobs and who pay taxes it'll hate
that help them grow and it is their
opinion I think and it's the way that
their members respond to this that I
think is the most important thing here
quasi quantum on Sunday there's more to
come are you planning more tax cuts I
think quasi quite is planning to lay out
our approach to getting the country's
finances responsibly managed in his uh
fiscal uh medium term fiscal plan on
November the 23rd
um that is what we should be focusing on
I don't expect that to uh involve
significant measures on the uh tax side
it'll be looking at a long-term fiscal
uh prognosis okay so if you so if you're
looking at the long-term fiscal
sustainability and it's not going to be
so much about tax the elephant in the
room is spending are you going to be
cutting spending look we're going to be
so first of all it's really important to
say we are going to be sticking within
the existing spending envelope that's
the comprehensive spending review 2021
envelope set out a year or so ago that
is very important because we're going to
live within those means that means they
make sure well no you can look at it
yourself you'll see where what it sets
out it means that public services are
properly and with inflation going funded
tax changes that you want to see it
means spending carts doesn't it well the
comprehensive spending review like set
out the spending envelope we are going
to stick to that spending envelope which
makes your public services are properly
and responsibly uh funded beyond that
we're going to make sure that in the
medium term that debt to GDP figure
which is already the second lowest in
the G7 is on a downward trajectory over
the median term that is the responsible
thing to do and that's what the
chancellor quasi-quarting will be doing
on November the 23rd my colleague Sam
coat says the cabinet have already been
asked to find efficiency savings is that
true
well the government always wants to
operate more efficiently we want to make
sure that our taxpayers money money paid
by you know our neighbors my
constituents is spent as well as
possible and that it's prioritized
towards projects which deliver growth
you know infrastructure for example we
talked a lot about getting more
infrastructure built so obviously we're
constantly looking at that but I was
going to emphasize again we're going to
be sticking to the existing spending
envelope which was set out a year ago it
covers a three-year period we're in the
first of those three years now it makes
your public services are properly and
responsibly funded and we're sticking to
that so it's pretty clear that you say
you're sticking to the uh the envelopes
but with inflation that is going to be a
squeeze for many uh different uh
departments real terms cut you're also
well don't forget this spending review
by the way did entail
um real-time increases when it was
written so just keep that in mind but
that was before inflation went to 10
yeah although inflation affecting the
public sector isn't as high as 10 for
various reasons we can get into if you
want okay um let's let's not do that
although I'm sure that many headphones
and hospitals will still be looking at
the energy energy bills that they're
facing but of course but of course
hospitals and schools are beneficiaries
of the business energy price guarantee
as much as you and I as individuals are
as well okay now
you speak you're not gonna I just want
to have a little look at the recent
polls that we've seen as well because
this is something that a lot of your
colleagues are going to be concerned
about they're going to have a look at
the market reaction to the budget and
they're also going to be looking at
things like this which is you know the
latest uh polling showing at record
labor leads up at 45 for labor the
conservatives on 28 you speak to your
colleagues is it right that letters of
no confidence the Prime Minister have
already started going in well I've
certainly haven't heard about that and
I'd be astonished if that was if that
was true like what matters isn't that a
snap opinion poll done on a particular
day of the week it's not it it's a
longer term Trend than that well I'll
tell you what the longer term trend is
going to be the longer term trend is
going to be getting growth going which
the growth plan will deliver and when
that delivers higher growth to this
country we're going to see wages going
up we're going to see more and better
jobs getting created we're going to see
a more sustainable tax base to fund
public services that is what I think the
public want and expect to see and when
that growth plan delivers in the
fullness of time I think the public will
be enthusiastic about that as people
like the British trainers well and as
people like the British Chambers of
Commerce the Federation of small
businesses and the confederation of
British industry are enthusiastic about
it already two very quick questions to
end because we are out of time are you
going to recall Parliament uh well
that's not my decision I haven't heard
that being discussed we've got party
conferences going on
um so I mean that's not my job to decide
that but I haven't heard that suggested
and also where is Liz Truss
well I met this truss in number 10
Downing Street about an hour ago do you
not think that she should be out
reassuring people when we've about to
see a run on Pension funds when the bank
of England had to step in why haven't we
heard from her well at least trust is
busy you know running the country she's
busy setting our policies we were
discussing uh the medium term fiscal
plan uh with her the chancellor and I um
and she's getting on with her job as you
would expect her to be okay thank you
very much indeed thank you
well that was the chief secretary to the
treasury Chris philp a little earlier
and just to give you a bit of an update
you might have heard the uh it's like
ding dong we were having about the graph
showing the yield on 30-year guilts now
it has it is correct to say that it has
dropped sharply down to just under 3.4
although that of course is after the
intervention from the bank of England so
after the uh intervention from the uh
Bank of England their Shields have gone
down now labor wrapped up its conference
in Liverpool today and it's clear the
party has a spring in its step after a
well-received leader speech yesterday
and strong poll leads and all that
before more financial turbulence today
kirstama has called for the immediate
recall of parliament over the economic
crisis well we can speak now to the
Shady Shadow attorney general Emily at
Thornbury who joins us now thank you
very much for being on the program today
at Miss Thornbury I'm not sure if you
caught the whole of the interview with
Chris philp the main takeaway for me was
when I asked him if they were going to
change course he said no we're not
what'd you make of it
I know the complacency is just
extraordinary everybody else in the
country all commentators around the
world are unanimous in saying they have
made An Almighty mistake with our
economy
and they're just gonna blunder on what
we need is we need the government to
come back to Parliament it's the
appropriate place for them to come and
to reassure the markets that they have a
plan for for funding these tax cuts I
have to say why we're going through all
of this why are they trashing the
economy for the sake of one percent of
people getting more money on the back of
unfunded tax cuts I don't know but in
any event they've spooked the markets
because of the way that they have been
talking it wasn't just what they did it
was also what they uh briefed they
briefed that they were going to go
further I thought it was interesting
that Chris Phelps didn't seem to be
talking about cutting the sorry bringing
in the personal allowance for higher
rate taxpayers which was something they
were briefing so perhaps they've gone
back on that but they're still talking
about they're not going to tell us how
they're going to pay for all this stuff
until the 23rd of November that and what
is going to happen in the meantime the
markets need reassuring what we're going
to see I think is
swanking onto the stage in Birmingham
for the Party Conference and telling us
all that everything is fine and that any
problems that there are are not his
fault and that he's doing the right
thing and I have two thousand of the
Tory faithful telling him that he's
right whereas the rest of us will be
holding our heads and our hands and
thinking what are they doing there's one
thing that I don't understand right
because Labor's made a big deal of being
the economically credible uh party the
party of you know sound money of
economic discipline at your conference
you were talking there about unfunded
tax cuts fiscally irresponsible tax cuts
but labor would keep the 1p cut the
basic rate of income tax and you say
that you would reinstate the 45p rate
but then you would immediately spend
that money so that's not being fiscally
responsible either is it because you do
exactly the same thing in fiscal terms
so I think it's there's a number of
things let me just give me a moment to
answer it so the first thing is is that
unfortunately we fear that we're not I
mean hopefully we'll be in government in
two years time but it's two years and so
you know the the 19 Pence tax rate will
be embedded by that stage into our our
fiscal system and frankly we haven't
gone into a single election and since
including 1997 saying that we were going
to raise the basic rate of tax that
isn't what we do that isn't what we're
about we're not about increasing the tax
burden on working people so it will have
been worked through by that stage the
question is really is how do they deal
with the emergency now you know the
emergency of their Creation with them
saying we're going to do this we're
going to do that we're going to do this
and it's all going to be on the back of
yet more borrowing a hint we may do more
hint we may start cutting public
services and this is just not the way
that you increase growth if you're going
to increase
borrowing you do it in order to properly
invest which doesn't mean a sugar rush
of giving tax cuts to the richest it
means doing things like we've said which
is setting up a Great British Energy
company that will be publicly owned and
they will increase the amount of energy
that we create within our own country so
that we're not dependent on Putin so
that we're able to get to Net Zero
faster and so we're able to push down
the energy bills I mean that's how you
ought to spend money that's what you
should be doing that's a kind of real
plan not what they're up to which is
just looking after their mates so given
that you say that you know the levels of
borrowing are uncomfortable given that
you say that labor doesn't want to go
into an election promising
um tax Rises for working people are you
also going to go into the next election
promising to spend more money on health
and education given there's no money no
more money left
so there's a number of things that we
have said already we've said as a
principle that we need to have a fair
attack system that we have at the moment
and we've begun to show the way in which
we would go so we would not be cutting
corporation tax for example
um and if they there wasn't the cut the
corporation tax then that would be 18
billion we would have a windfall on
those on those energy companies that at
the moment are making enormous profits
they were never expecting to make those
profits but on the back of what's
happening internationally prices have
gone up so much that they're making
whacking great profits and we've said
well we ought to have a windfall tax on
them the government for reasons which
are Beyond understanding are saying
they're not prepared to to tax these
days
they have introduced one window yeah
yeah but but since then the prices
continue to go up and will continue to
go up so their profits will continue to
go up and the person in charge of BP for
example says that it's like having a
cash machine yeah yeah when he's when
it's put to him which is one of the Tory
defenses which is oh well these
companies will stop investing if we tax
them too hard he says no no no we
continue investing okay so all of this
is nonsense we would change the non-dom
status and the rules in relation to that
that would make us uh three billion so
there's a series of things so we would
be doing differently to the government
and of course I mean the one thing I
agree with Christopher on is he says
every pound should count well done right
right I do what do you squeeze one more
question in if I may because you and I
both been in Liverpool at Labor
conference I don't know if you agree
with me but it felt to me like the most
buoyant frankly labor conference that I
can remember in quite a long time and
there's been numerous polls of course
showing a rather healthy uh poll lead
for the labor party do you think you're
going to win the next election
yes I know be fine
I can't say yes or no because I don't
want to say anything for granted and I
know that here isn't either we really
want to have the opportunity to serve
and we will be asking the British public
in two years time okay thank you very
much indeed Emily Thornbury there for
the labor party well as we get towards
the end of an extraordinary day uh
Deputy political editor Sam coats has
hot footed it back from Liverpool this
morning I think was it on on the train
from Liverpool he's back now uh here in
Westminster with us
what a day what is going on in the
government right now
right now
number 10 reject that Friday's big
statement all those tax cuts and all
that additional borrowing 72 billion
pounds extra borrowings until April that
crazy needs in order to fund all those
tax cuts number 10 reject that is the
main reason for the terminal that we've
been seeing in the markets and the
emergency intervention by the bank of
it's quite incredible I mean the uh
Sterling was falling guilts rates of
borrowing costs going up pretty much
immediately after that statement which
happened on Friday morning but number 10
do not accept that one cabinet minister
today told me that it was BS if you
excuse the language
um that there is a link between one and
the other they also say well the
Situation's getting much better because
of the bank of England intervention in
any way this is all because of what's
going on overseas I understand some in
number 10 think this is primarily Sophie
a Communications problem and a problem
with how they've managed stakeholders
presumably uh the markets so there is a
sense
at the very center of government that
this isn't a crisis this isn't something
that requires a dramatic approach an
all-encompassing Focus they seem to be
taking it in their stride doing other
things concentrating on other issues as
we go along then we head towards
conservative conference and they don't
think they're to blame now a lot of Tory
MPS disagree with that got a lot of
global Economic Institutions the markets
the global Banks disagree with number
10. this is very serious so it feels
like there has been I guess a certain
amount of shock surprise since what
happened on Friday at both from the
markets but also from concept of MPS
should people be surprised
I think some of some of the surprise
bluntly is people not paying enough
attention we knew quite a lot of what
was going to happen on Friday well in
advance we also knew the warnings about
what would happen if they did what they
did on Friday and the consequences that
was the subject of the leadership
contest on the one side you had Liz
trust promising massive tax cuts funded
by borrowing all the way through and on
the other side her rival where she's
doing like all the way through was
saying if you do that you basically run
on the pound and government borrowing
costs going up there could be a
financial crisis if you do that we've
known that for months so there's no
point in pretending that this is all
some dramatic job yes Liz truss's uh
mini budget went further than we were
expecting on Friday although Christopher
is right to say that proportionately the
bits that we're most surprised about
didn't go it weren't the biggest costs
in that budget but conservative members
the 80 000 also people that decided who
on current prime minister is did so
having heard the the warnings the expert
advice and deciding actively to reject
that and that's why we are where we are
today Sam thank you very much indeed
we'll have more from Sam later on the
program
now the UK is a significant global
economy but it's far from being the
biggest so it doesn't that often make
headlines all around the world but it
did this week although maybe not for the
right reasons
this morning the British pound plunged
nearly five percent to a record low
against the US dollar British pound has
crashed to a record low against the US
dollar the British pound hitting an
all-time low today against the dollar
yeah so here's what happened Liz truss
introduced a round of tax cuts for the
wealthy and in response the British
currency has collapsed I think the UK is
behaving a bit like an emerging market
do we have the ingredients required to
have that self-fulfilling downward
spiral
I think it's something worse
unfortunately I don't want it to be
worse this is the country I earn my
money in I'm long Sterling and naturally
from my my salary this is a UK fueling a
global development that is resulting in
significant damage both to Global
markets and the global economy and over
the weekend the the chancellor in a
Schoolboy era then says more of this
stuff is coming
so chaos Reigns
I wonder if the new prime minister Liz
truss was watching a little earlier I
spoke to the man that some call her
favorite Economist that's Jared Lyons
and I started by asking if the
government is right by trying to say
this terminal is primarily down to
Global forces
the reality is that there's three
different things happening uh first the
government is right the global backdrop
is very difficult very febrile financial
markets and interest rates in the
western economies and borrowing rates of
Western economies have risen
significantly in recent months then
second on top of that last Thursday the
bank of England increased interest rates
in the UK by not as much as the markets
probably had hoped for but at the same
time the bank of England said that they
were going to be selling guilts over the
next year which the markets didn't like
that added to the supply of government
debt but the third factor in particular
was the mini budget so one has to say of
all the events it was the mini budget
that was the most significant but the
backdrop was both those global factors
in the Bank of England last Thursday and
in terms of the mini budget there were
lots of good things in the many budget
in terms of aims at the pro growth
agenda Confederation British industry
liked to The Institute of directors
liked it that as I warmed about
beforehand and as I was worried out on
day and as the markets are now showing
the bank at the markets were not liking
the fact that the government
borrowed too much they announced the
whole series of measures that the market
expected but then they went that one
extra step they announced some tax
changes that the markets were not
comfortable with I think the markets
were overly worried about the
inflationary implications of those extra
tax changes but in particular and I can
understand that the markets were worried
about the affordability largely because
they were not prepared for it so for
instance the tax change for higher
earners in economic terms was not so
significant but it was like the last
straw that broke the camels back the
chancellor while he had focused on the
general public and on British businesses
he had not really prepared the financial
markets fully and I think he had taken
his eye off the ball slightly shall we
say in having not prepared the markets
for what he was doing in the budget and
I felt that he overstepped the mark last
week so it was the combination of all
three factors the febrile markets
because the global backdrop the actions
of the bank of England last Thursday but
let's be no doubt it was primarily the
mini budget last Friday that triggered
this leads a series of events I have to
say listening to you uh I am quite
struck by the change in the attitude
that I am seeing when we spoke before
the budget
um it felt to me like you were quite
excited about the Liz trust economic
plan you were excited about the fact
that it was gonna in your view help
growth now you're saying that the
chancellor is overstepped the mark and
there was things in the budget
specifically that have frightened the
markets
um have you changed your view
no no let's be quite clear
um it was very positive in many respects
the budget or the mini budget last
Friday because the mini budget was very
much aimed at a pro growth agenda and
that's really good we need to break out
of this low growth phase and we need to
move to a more supply side driven
investment-led agenda challenge though
was that as one moved towards the budget
last Friday particularly given the
backdrop internationally and that the
bank of England as I said the bank of
England tightening policy it was vitally
important I would say that the
government or the chancellor took the
financial markets with him I was writing
last week in particular in the week
before about the very febrile state of
the markets so coming back to your
question though there was a whole series
of very positive things in the mini
budget but what one needs to say is that
if we take three different Target
audiences general public now the mini
budget really helped them because by
having the energy price tag and by
reversing those plan tax increases
corporation tax and National Insurance
the combination of all that effectively
have stopped the economy falling into a
potentially very deep recession and stop
things falling into a situation where
the public finances would have been
blown out of the water now the second
target audience was the British business
community and as I say the CBI
Confederation British industry did
Street directors were very positive and
that's because there were lots of very
pro-investment measures announced in the
budget and the marker for further steps
in the future that was really good but
the third group was the markets were
very nervous ahead of budget now if the
chancellor had just stuck to what the
markets had expected which is actually
what I thought he was going to do then
it would have all been fine so in
addition to the Energy tab of the
additional borrowing 82 Pence of each
extra pounds borrowed was reversing
those two plan tax increases if it had
just been that it would have been really
fine but what we saw was maybe for
whatever reason the chancellor just
decided to do a little bit more and in
and themselves you might say each
individual item wasn't particularly
expensive but it was the fact that the
markets were in the three bar State and
they were worried about the
affordability the ability to service the
debts shall we say so overall lots of
positives it wasn't communicated well
and maybe not handled well at the last
minute but putting it all together
coming back to your question I think the
pro growth strategy is very good but
what we now have is the aftermath of the
events of last week and what we need to
see is a period of stability return to
financial markets you say that a period
of stability is needed do you think
spending cuts are necessary
um well in terms of that that's not the
immediate issue in my mind when one of
those fiscal policy and I'm surprised
we're having to wait till late November
the fiscal principles I think are very
important physical principles are very
much about stabilizing the economy in
the near term so he should do something
quicker you think then well actually
last Friday he announced measures to
stabilize the economy in the near term
by ruling out the Deep recession but
what I'm saying in terms of quicker in
terms of bringing those principles
forward just because if you can the
principles are quite clear it's about
having fiscal discipline and that's
about reducing debt to GDP you said that
you warned before the budget about the
risks of borrowing and also the risk of
not taking the market along with the
government you've been described as Liz
truss's favorite Economist did you have
any conversations with her or her team
um well obviously the prime minister in
the last couple weeks has been
preoccupied with other issues uh but
yeah I I made my thoughts uh known lots
of positives about the budget I
obviously didn't know what the detail
was going to be in it because I'm not
inside the tent so to speak but I was
highlighting indeed writing as you
probably have seen about the febrile
states of the markets and the need to
keep the markets on side So within the
overall context the economic story is a
positive one a pro-growth agenda but
there's no doubt that in these sorts of
environments as one saw last week it was
necessary to particularly as it wasn't a
budget that was fully funded
the opr wasn't giving the announcements
it was there for brainport to get the
fiscal principles across last week and
they didn't they didn't take your advice
on that
well
um yeah sometimes people listen
sometimes they don't but there were
positives that came out of it but
um as we saw last Friday it was just not
um keeping things into line with what
the markets had been prepped for and
were expecting
Jared Lyons there you're watching the
take we're live in Westminster for you
this evening up next we'll be talking to
our viewers panel and find out what
people at home make of the growing
economic crisis
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take now it has even
by the standards of recent times been
yet another extraordinary uh week and
it's only Wednesday let's have a listen
we've woken up to a new record low for
the pound its value sank against the US
dollar all this will require a
significant monetary policy response
mortgage lenders have pulled their best
fixed rate deals after the bank of
England said it will raise interest
rates by as much as needed this line
getting higher and higher as it gets
higher our mortgage costs are creeping
up as well and then finally that's where
we are today the world we're heading for
is a bumpy few weeks the chancellor is
going to have quite a tough time because
he's now promised to set our plans to
balance the books
I'm not going to make any comment now
we've just heard from the bank of
England just now uh Jane with uh a
rather extraordinary statement saying
that they are planning a guilt Market
operation every major economy is dealing
with exactly these same issues and I'm
told that there were a number a swayed
of Pension funds that were it not for
the government's intervention would have
essentially collapsed been insolvent by
this afternoon and she needs to come to
Parliament straight away and reverse
that budget welcome to a special safety
bridge on Sunday we're live here in
Liverpool at the labor Party Conference
it will fall to us to fix the damage
that the Tories have done as in 1945
1964 1997 this is a labor moment and
together with the British people we will
do it thank you conference
[Applause]
well as we gear up for the conservative
party conference let's find out what the
most important people you at home make
of everything that's going on at the
moment just how worried our viewers
panel is uh hear you all are thank you
very much for being with us this evening
it's great to see everybody here well
let's crack straight on shall we go to a
Ian first we're going to talk to Ian
Michael John first a labor voter you're
talking to us from Newbury in what do
you make of you know the interviews that
we've had so far the government says
that they are not going to change their
course
well it's absolutely fascinating that uh
the conservative party the government is
the only one in Step the rest of the
world has got it wrong hasn't understood
what they're doing and the run on the
pound is obviously some terrible mistake
it's not it's awful it's Dreadful it's
frightening and whatever
budgetary benefit there may be for uh
the ordinary working person by way of
tax cuts is quite likely to be eaten up
by increased mortgages by the cost of
living by General inflation much of
which it seems May well be caused by
this particular budget
okay so in unhappy with a with a thought
that the government wants to continue
with its plan let's get the view of Vic
Daniels now shall we conservative photo
you're talking to us from West London
are you pleased that the government is
sticking to its plans
um please I'm confident and I'm
motivated Sophie
um you know I run a small business 120
130 people totally demotivated about the
increases in National Insurance and also
the proposed increase in corporation tax
um over the last five days we've got
more jobs out for higher than ever
before we're all in stock in Step we're
all motivated uh and we all want to work
harder work longer get more people on
the payroll make more money pay more tax
employ more people and ensure that
there's more money available to to the
public services so as a small business
person I'm in a very good place at the
moment really interesting to hear a
different perspectives on this both of
you very energized for different reasons
right let's go to Izar shall we this is
27 years old which is why I want to talk
to you because obviously the increase
borrowing some would say is going to be
people like yourselves who might be
paying that off
yeah it's frustrating that during a
period of kind of record low interest
rates the government cared about fiscal
discipline and it was all about keeping
the balance the budget balance but now
as soon as rates are starting to go up
the government is like happy to spend on
all sorts of kind of tax cuts largely
for the rich which are not even going to
be very effective at stimulating growth
well interesting and do you do you not
think though that some people are saying
that actually it will stimulate the
economy I mean that's the argument we
heard from Chris philp he said that it's
all about growth that helps everyone
because it helps people create jobs and
it helps Drive wages up
well I think if you look at the data so
the IMF did a massive report in 2015
that showed that actually these kind of
tax cuts just increase inequality and
they don't stimulate very much growth
and if they do it's very very narrow I
think realistically there were a whole
bunch of things they could have done to
stimulate growth the highest effective
tax rate is actually for those who are
on the Universal Credit earnings taper
which is a 55 tax rate they could have
looked at that they could have looked at
things like child care to improve labor
force participation which massively
tanks during the pandemic and hasn't
really recovered since so it's actually
just frustrating to see that they've
opted for a policy that doesn't really
have any evidence well let's see what
happens at the next policy review shall
we really interesting to hear your
thoughts thanks very much is our let's
get closed view next and we can talk to
Chloe who is our nurse you're talking to
us from Cumbria now I've got you down on
my sheet as conservative because she
voted conservative at the last election
but it's fair to say that you've been
wavering a bit since then
yeah I think from seeing the labor
conference as well
um they're a lot more in touch aren't
they with the regular working person I
mean the mini budget they need to get
rid of that completely and we've now got
the chancellor that doesn't you know he
has no comment when he's questioned
about it and we've got a prime minister
that has been nowhere to be seen and
which doesn't really give you much Faith
um
in any of this really and I think I mean
I've spoken to people just today who
have then said you know like one of my
friends she's got a 500 pound gas and
electric bill so you know they have to
go you have to go to work more to pay
your bill there's then higher for you
not to be there because you having to go
to work more and one of my other friends
today he said he's really concerned
about the interest rate so his mortgage
so he's the same you know he's now
really concerned about having to go to
work more you know not even being in the
house that he's having to pay more for
and I think it's a really a really
frightening time and I think
um it's really going to start affecting
people's mental health as well I think
there'll be a massive increase
in in things like that I'm just Keen to
talk a little bit at the end thank you
very much Chloe about at Labor
conference and just to get people's
views I guess on what they made of you
know kirst armor and labor conference
more why do we can let's talk to Stella
shall we uh Stella Findlay you're
talking to us from Newcastle you
describe yourself as a green or a lib
Den voter what did you make of cursed
armor
um well I wasn't too impressed with Kia
skarma
um I think his delivery was as though
he'd learned a speech and
um there wasn't very much passion or
enthusiasm there
um and I think a lot of the promises
that he made
are not promises that you can keep so I
don't think that we can really trust
what he's going to do in the future
um but what I find more worrying is
about
um the conservatives who I think are
even worse than Kirsten and his
um cabinet that um they don't accept
responsibility for the effects of that
many budget and if they accept a
responsibility that it has had that
effect and then said what the future is
going to hold and that the future might
be better for us instead of just
disappearing and not saying anything
about it then we might have more
confidence in the government but it's
very worrying that
and I don't feel we can trust the labor
party not a great situation for you to
be in there Stella well let's go to our
swing voter now at shall we uh this is
Belinda Campbell you're talking to us
from uh Twickenham in South West London
swing voter convinced by case Dharma
I do think they all put on big adverts
for themselves sorry to say that and um
you wonder why they haven't done any of
these things before
um they want to take each other's place
um I thought it was quite passionate and
there's a lot of clapping and you want
to believe that it's all going to happen
and it's all truthful and you know
govern with Integrity he said so I want
to believe it I really do and
um
all of us just want to feel more secure
because it is frightening I just got a
text from my sister in Switzerland and
she said you know I'm so worried and I'm
thinking of you all there so people are
very worried and um with you know the
lady just said about mental health I
mean that all started in the lockdown
people's mental health was compromised
work worrying time slightly thank you so
much uh indeed uh always a pleasure to
talk to you guys so we do appreciate you
giving up a little chunk of your
Wednesday night thank you very much well
that was what our viewers uh panel made
of it all let's have a look at what the
polls are saying shall we can bring in
our Deputy political editor uh Sam coats
let's have a quick look shall we what
polls have you got for us well hopefully
up on the wall in a second we've got the
latest yougov poll now this shows a
17-point lead for the labor party 45 for
labor conservatives on 28 liberal
Democrats bit low actually online uh
greens sucking up quite a lot of uh the
sort of Center left vote now this is
really interesting there is a clear lead
for the labor party and the question
always for me is what's going on under
the Bonnet what's moved around that
means that we've seen one of the highest
leads for the labor party and the answer
Sophie is this but you dig down into the
numbers you discover that K starma who
has traditionally up until this point
had a bit of a problem the older people
get has started actually to make some
progress so
um really previously Kirsten has
struggled and lost amongst everybody
over 50. uh now he's pulling ahead in
the 50 to 64 year old category and
although he's not ahead in the 65 plus
category he has dramatically closed the
Gap now all of that's just on a month
ago so that seems to suggest that the
transition from Boris Johnson to Liz to
us is just starting to decouple that
link between older voters and the
conservative party and that is a really
big and important thing it's something
by the way that actually the lead party
had noticed I talked to Shadow cabinet
members up in Liverpool who had clocked
out and it's something that they want to
build on interesting really interesting
and that photo group always so reliable
ever the conservatives could things be
changing Sam always a pleasure uh to
talk
you're watching the take we are live in
Westminster up next we are going to be
talking to our economics editor Ed
Conway for his first letter appearance
on the take about the extraordinary
events of today
thank you
[Music]
hello welcome back to Westminster you're
watching the take well at times like
this it's always worth talking to our
economics and data editor Ed Conway so
we've managed to sneak him on to the
program at site which I'm very happy
about Ed firstly can you just explain to
us
what happened today and why is it
important well it's it's kind of
incredibly complicated at one level you
know the functioning of some of these
Pension funds is is pretty abstruse but
you know pragmatically speaking what's
happening is that the entire economic
system as we know you know our lives to
some extent depend on what's happening
in Government Bond markets it's kind of
the basis the foundation stone uh for so
much of what constitutes the financial
World whether it's Pension funds or
whether it's mortgages and that is
essentially facing a Shockwave at the
moment those yields have gone up an
enormous amount which has impacts all
the way down the line so you're seeing
various chain reactions that are kind of
unexpected which is in some senses
similar to what we saw in the financial
crisis uh you know a decade and a better
go we're just unexpected things happen
when a certain Market goes a little bit
haywire and that's basically what's
happened with Pension funds and you've
seen the bank of England intervene here
and as a result of that well the bank is
spending a lot more money they have they
say uh averted what I'm told was looking
for a moment like a run Dynamic when
they say run dynamic in kind of Central
Bank the Central Banking world you know
that's similar in a kind of wholesale
sense so rather than being kind of
people queuing on the street but in a
wholesale sense similar to what you saw
uh with Northern rocks so the risk of a
kind of spiral well they got there and
they got there kind of before it
actually turned into that spiral I know
how do you think just quickly how do you
think the markets will react to what
Chris philp told us tonight that the
government is not going to change Force
they think of course that they think
it's because of global events not the
budget yeah I mean we're just gonna have
to wait and see and and that is
definitely the message from from
government from Chris a fascinating
interview and
it's hard it's hard to believe that it
was just a coincidence that's the thing
that I think people will be a little bit
skeptical about you know this is the
only time we've ever had a reaction
quite like this straight after a budget
so is it just bad luck that this has
happened or is there some cause and
effect and most people I talk to in
markets think there was a cause and
effect from this budget Ed thank you
very much indeed really interesting to
talk what an extraordinary day uh thank
you for spending at some of your evening
with us here on the take we'll be back
next week and every week Wednesday at 9
00 p.m see you at next Sunday at the
Conservative Party Conference
foreign
[Music]